[Music]
all right
a tweet went viral recently and it says
aunt dai is my favorite chinese
restaurant in montreal
but the real treat is the menu featuring
extremely honest commentary
from the owner yes so this is
here are some examples that was tweeted
out
so it has like the name of the dish the
price
the photo of the dish and then the
owner's words which say
this one for example says comparing to
our general tao chicken
this one is not that good anyway i'm not
a big fan of north american chinese food
and it's your call
that's pretty cool chinese words though
is it translated
uh it looks like it's because you know
how it says chinese
okay owner's words i thought that's a
chinese word owners owner's words
never mind and then there is a
translation like in english orange b
yeah yeah and then oh that's a
pronunciation
nope is it yeah
oh yeah opinion
yeah okay that's crazy i didn't even
that's all
i don't even try i like that though you
know when you go to like a restaurant
you talk to the server i'm like hey
what's your favorite
you're like how do i put this thing
you're like
dude i like when the server's like i
don't get that i hate that yeah
but then sometimes i'm like wait a
minute i want this right now
this is what i want and then you get it
you regret it i'm not going to offend
you
am i if i get this because i'm not
listening to your word on give a [ __ ]
now you ever feel bad when you ask them
for the recommendation and then
you don't ignore it get it yeah i'm
always like oh now i feel like i have to
get the macaroons
people pleasers man i never feel bad you
people please
no cause i'll go like i'm like if the
president came here right now
what would you offer them as a
representation of your store
and sometimes they're like oh you do use
that president one i do right yeah and
then they'll be like
oh i would recommend something looks
like some say some [ __ ] like some
vegetables fried rice
nah [ __ ] that i'm like let me get that
or they're like well i'm a republican
they can eat
[ __ ] what do you think of that
that's what i say i always ask what's
popular here
like what do people usually get and then
they'll tell me their main
like biggest sellers and then that's
kind of where i go from
but then what if everyone's just asking
what's the biggest seller and then
that's what's
making it the biggest element because
hands down i think the best curry
well previous to curry house shutting
down is actually koraku and i
i still like the curry there better oh
that's good there but koraku
is known for the ramen so everyone goes
there for like ramen and stuff and i'm
like
that's not where you go for you go there
for the curry
where is that little tokyo they've been
around since like the 60s
is that the one you guys got delivered
here no i don't know if they do delivery
is it the one that kind of looks like an
old diamond i would judge it's like
orange inside yeah they cook it on this
side yeah it's right next to like milk
and tea
and it's been a long time man they've
been around for ages i
remember going to high school dude one
of the only reasons i don't want to move
to las vegas nevada is because we have
the bombest [ __ ] thai food next to us
there's really good thai food in nevada
good food
i don't want to lose it because i found
this one spot that's so [ __ ] good and
i'm like oh i don't want to
chance it we when we go we're gonna
we're gonna go to one of our fans places
well i didn't know
when i went there that a fan owned it
man it it's
it's pretty damn good it's called uh oh
uh it starts with the s lotus of siam i
think
okay oh it's thai food it's really
[ __ ] good
and it's in vegas like a las vegas yeah
it's in vegas beautiful
we were going to another one and that
one was closed so in the same plaza
i was like that one has a line let's go
there and then
man it was [ __ ] good nice yeah i
think it'll blow your mind i think i
think it's worth it is it real spicy too
like thai spicy spicy i bet it can be
but they just have a lot of good stuff
all right back to the
this chinese menu so another dish here
it's a saute sauce beef
and it says owner's words this is new on
our menu and i did not have a chance to
try this one yet
according to a lot of customers this one
is very popular i still don't have
a chance to taste it looks like i should
spend more time eating in my own
restaurant that's pretty funny
don't get this one this is my
mother-in-law's recipe man
next one says for this like curry thing
it doesn't have the name of the dish but
it says it has curry flavor
don't expect it to be so tasty but it's
a safe choice and make you happy
make you so happy what is that egg oh oh
that's that singapore vermicelli thing
oh it looks like an omelet from here i
know
that's that like you can get that all
these cafes right over here it's like a
singapore vermicelli with the curry
sauce so does the owner have
any positive reviews like purely
positive like this one's my
favorite uh let's keep reading he likes
the napkins and he likes the ketchup
that's what i'm afraid he doesn't even
like chinese food actually i wanted to
open up a mcdonald's franchise but you
know
my parents didn't let me so i had to
take over the restaurant
so this one has the ingredients potatoes
chili vinegar owner's words this plate
will show you how chinese cuisine can do
with our beloved potato outside of
french fries
mashed potato chips this potato julienne
dish is very very popular in china
let's salute potato i never had a potato
dish in chinese food
my mom makes something like that like a
shredded potato like soy sauce oh
shoot it says chips like like the london
chips
the one that my mom makes isn't crispy
it's not like fried or anything
is it like hash browns yeah it looks
like hashbrowns but it's not stuck
together like a hash brown
interesting you think outside of french
fries and chips so he's like oh i see
potatoes that aren't fries this is it
got it yeah
so then this is the last oh no wait
second to last
owner's words little little bit spicy
morphe
human very tasty we used to we used to
have the beef pieces on small sticks but
several customers cut their lips
by thinking it was some hard ingredient
they must have watched some shows about
weird chinese food
to avoid incidents like this no more
sticks some good infusion from the
overly fried onion slices which you can
eat
definitely recommend this very anal
like very specifically anal like they're
tired of these [ __ ] questions huh
yeah there's only details that you don't
need oh yeah this thing used to have
sticks but then we saw this thing on tv
so there's no sticks anymore we got rid
of it
because people ripping their [ __ ]
mouths up on it actually it's like what
why did you even need to say that i kind
of like that i love it tmi
because i'm like that's it just gives
insight in like the customer base i
don't know it's really like
i'm nosy like that i want to know these
details like we used to serve this in
bowls but dumb [ __ ] kept on
spilling it so now i have to put it on a
plate because we're too stupid
originally it wasn't on skewers it was
so
cool but these dumbasses were [ __ ]
jousting each other with it
here's the last one people were poking
their eyes out it says
all right did you want to no no please
did you are you sure no
no no i'm good i'm very good please all
right it says what's this a rom-com
says this is the number one choice dish
ordered by chinese customers across
whole china according to an internet
survey and i totally believe that
when i was china and went to a
restaurant i always ordered this dish
it's so popular that it has so many
different versions in china
since i have so high expectation on the
dish i am not a huge fan of our version
to be honest
but don't get me wrong the plate at our
restaurant is very tasty too it's just
different from those
where i went to university i'm starting
with this is that that's so famous i
don't know
the pork wood ear bamboo shoots
green peppers red peppers oh what is
that
what's wood here woody it's like a type
of like i think like mushroom mushroom
right
yeah is that right i'm starting to think
like literally i wonder
if they're like if their english is bad
that's why it sounds like that or
they're just really bad at typing
there's a bunch of typos
when i was china when i was china man
ren what
dish out of all of these which one would
you order from everything that just got
pitched
the noodle one the single board curry
one the the yellow
you said it was noodle no yeah
vermicelli oh yeah yeah yeah why you've
had that before that's what they usually
call it i just like
the way he described it yeah don't
expect it to be so
tasty so you don't like flavorful dishes
is that what it is
no no i do but i like i i'm uh
safe choice attracted to like noodles
and stuff so
even when they tell you this is not so
great i'll try it well
like steve like oh you don't think it's
good um
i will take that damn right that's good
i will be disappointed and be like i
don't want to go here anymore
but it's my fault yeah i challenge them
and i go
it's actually good i'm like it's the
best meal i've ever had i'm too prideful
i'll be like what are you talking about
you're lying excuse me while i go
diarrhea
but yeah so the owner said that the
reason why he decided to do this is
because
um he just wanted to answer questions
because a lot of people ended up
ordering something that they did not end
up liking and so he just wanted to give
as much description as possible so his
customers [ __ ] annoyed of his
customers huh plain or whatever like
they can fully
be informed on the dish that they're
about to order that's so funny
yeah that's so [ __ ] funny let me just
do it all at once so you know he's doing
a pre-emptive strike here on the menu
nelson what are you getting it wasn't
one that they said it was really good
that's what i'm getting like the one
that they said
it's all over all over china then theirs
might not have been the one before that
the one before where he's like do you
rip your [ __ ] mouth up with
i'm the kind of person when i go to a
restaurant it doesn't matter what i'm in
the mood for
if that restaurant is known for that
thing i would get that me too so
cause even if it's like something weird
i've never had before in my life like i
like
trying different new things so
especially if they're known for it
same here yeah he said that was the only
one he's like this is really tasty but
then he went way too long on like how
you stab your mouth or whatever
so you never go to a place based off of
what you crave for that day
always well i go to that specific place
yeah so then it's probably for that
thing that they're known for that's why
i'm getting it because you're going for
that right like if you want like
i don't know like lobster you're not
going to go to like
olive garden or something right well
depends where you live
and the world that's true but then
sometimes i crave like a specific
dish that i get at a specific restaurant
like for example at
cheesecake factory it's the worst
example cheesecake factory is good we
talked about i love cheesecake there's
800 items
don't you dare talk [ __ ] about my
cheesecake and chocolate bread
i'm actually praising it they have the
best chinese food in the world and i
stand by that
they have everything they do that's what
i like about only ever ordered one dish
there what do you get
it's the chicken farfalli like that's my
favorite one and then the sauce that
they use too i always ask
them to make extra sauce for me i'm like
i love italiano
so totally just that dish and i'll just
go even though cheesecake factory has
like
millions of things to order from i just
get that one thing you know what i
haven't gone in ages
claim jumpers oh my god do they even
have those restaurants anymore dude a
buttermilk biscuit as big as tis [ __ ]
head right
on the plate hell he used to go a lot
eating like a lumberjack dude nope
miss claimed that [ __ ] was the bomb when
you're in there do you feel like you're
about to
mine some coal and [ __ ] i feel sad i
feel like i should have bought gold
equipment and not try to find gold
myself
i like those restaurants where there's
those peanut shells on the ground you
can just open peanut just throw it on
the ground oh yeah i mean not five guys
food wreckers yeah five guys yeah well
yeah five guys
uh there's that one barbecue joint in
norwalk that has that too
where there's full of peanuts on the
ground i think i'm too polite for it
because i always feel bad of the
employees when i just
like i'm supposed to throw it on the
ground so i put it on the counter
but then when you're walking in you're
crunching on all the ones well those
people are rude as [ __ ]
or you're being rude because now they
have to clean the [ __ ] table
oh no i'm saying i would put it down on
the table with my food and then i'd
throw it away when i'm done
i wouldn't like like yeah clean it up
i think they clean it up every night
those peanuts on the ground
i i think they should or maybe they just
leave it for the decor
i have a great a health thing i've never
been to one of these restaurants so i'm
just guessing it's part of the decor
you've never been to like just a five
guys or nothing wait did they leave
peanuts on the ground at fire
not anymore i haven't been to five guys
in like a year they did
well i went to one in santa monica like
last year and
it was clean i don't know i didn't see
[Music]
anything
[Music]
you